este momento y con el panorama que vive
ucrania se puede hablar de algún tipo de
éxito en los esfuerzos diplomáticos
me parece el único buenas tardes me
parece que el único éxito por el momento
es el hecho de que están hablando o sea
no dejan no cierran la puerta para poder
alcanzar alguna solución diplomática
pero los resultados directos y yo por el
momento no veo luego que la medición es
la propuesta de turquía y distrae el de
ser intermediario porque los dos países
a bordo de extraer parecen ser los
intermediarios perfectos a diferencia de
otros para ambos países porque cumplen
requisitos de confianza en dos lados
pero todavía hay que esperar hasta que
esto bueno he tenido este alcanzado
discúlpeme justamente lo que usted
estaba mencionando me gustaría que lo
mandara un poco que tan relevante puede
ser resultar una mediación de turquía o
de israel
turquía el presidente turco se ve por su
homólogo ruso como una persona parecida
a él en su vestido de administración en
su deseo de ser protagonista regional y
global de una líder fuerte entonces en
algunas cosas hablan el mismo idioma
en el mismo lenguaje
respecto a israel es un país con
lenguajes históricos muy fuertes tanto
con duscher como con ucrania yo creo que
más o menos un millón de los strikes
tienen orígenes ucranianos y rusos
muchos tienen familias o en rusia y
además extraer es un país que entiende
muy bien las zonas de seguridad tanto
para usted como la ucrania y en ese
aspecto puede entender nuevas
preocupaciones de los países eso es lo
que va a extraer más peso como posible
en intermediarios
que se puede interpretar de las
afirmaciones del presidente putin de
obtener sus objetivos por la negociación
o por la guerra hasta donde estaría
dispuesto a llegar
yo creo que eso es así el presidente
ruso está seguro ha sido de entender que
es tajantemente seguro en que los
objetivos militares la campaña si no se
está alcanzando entonces no tiene de
ahora porque ceder en manipulación para
siendo proponer lo mismo en la vez
negociación y estaría dispuesto pero
creo que no está pensando qué país está
perdiendo en el conflicto
bueno y en términos prácticos que se
espera de las negociaciones que se
retoman mañana puede haber algún tipo de
resultado para frenar las hostilidades o
al menos suspender las temporalmente
me parece que el único resultado que le
pueden lograr con el momento es lograr
un cese del fuego el derecho a entender
porque el acuerdo sobre el cese del
fuego no fue cumplido y elaborar
mecanismos más viables para que
funcionan los canales para la salud
humanitaria para la población civil el
indio no creo que haya habrá más
resultados por el momento pero eso es lo
que si pueden y deberían alcanzar en la
tercera ronda de municiones